schooled us DeFranco no Chester Android
simmerman says scooter cars are known
for good value that Kodiak is a
particular car but not terribly exciting
to drive we've come to Finland to see if
that can change when we put the Kodiaks
all-wheel drive system through its paces
Andrei moves to the passenger seat and
lets racing legend Hans Yocum stroke
take over under normal conditions the
all-wheel-drive system only sends power
to the front wheels but the rear wheels
can also be engaged when extra grip is
needed the electronic stability control
system provides an extra level of road
safety
[Music]
rook says that you can have a more
exciting drive by switching the ESC to
sport that gives you a bit more leeway
on turns but doesn't affect overall
safety but in the winter time even if
you got all the systems running you
shouldn't try anything fancy if you
drive too fast you'll just get into
trouble to catch that it's always a good
idea to drive defensively during the
winter don't tailgate and take curves
slowly you can speed up again once you
start moving out of them but what if you
do try to take a curve too quickly
Jakob says you should keep your foot on
the brake pedal the Kodiaks anti-lock
brakes prevent the wheels from locking
up but don't steer into the curve too
sharply the wheels will lose traction
and you'll get into trouble you can ease
up to get the situation under control
again as a feminist in Lincoln technique
first a nice level sock appears and this
is alpha who over the cryptically
of course
han-soo Aachen could do this sort of
driving in his sleep so now it's time
for Andre to take over let's see how he
does with the Kodiak in sport mode
Adri says it's a bit of work to
oversteer with this car you hunt you I
can points out that you just have to
slow down or speed up a little the
system kicks in automatically
yeah you see you steered right into it
and the system kicks in when you hit a
certain angle just seeing ideas law
activities anti says the Kodiak may look
kind of hokey but it takes curves pretty
well aren't you off him agrees the
steering is well matched to the
powertrain it's a fun car to drive but
everyone should try driving in icy
conditions as a precaution to get used
to it the streets in Germany are usually
kept clear in the winter but it's still
good to know how to handle these icy
conditions you could try it on a parking
lot that gets icy at night to find out
how your car responds to wintry
conditions Andre says it happens all the
time he just got your driver's license
it's been snowing and you try to find a
parking lot to practice on so you would
have your driving instructor show you
how to drive in snow knock'em says it's
important to get a feel for how the
anti-lock braking system works and that
just takes practice
you can't just slam on the brakes and
expect the system to work but EBS can
make all the difference when it comes to
avoiding accidents
now Andre is going to test the Kodiak
all by himself
he's on an oval track so there aren't a
lot of unexpected curves and that means
he can really push the car to its limits
well geometry magazine he crashed in
Kodiak Ankush bakoma
and so foot off the gas making the back
and seem lighter and then if you
accelerate and play around with a
steering you'll have to look out the
side window to see where you're going
Andriy says that you can really have fun
with this car at least on closed tracks
but only if you've had a winter driving
course